I'd like to talk to
you about solving
these kinematics problems.
So we're going to actually
start by asking ourselves
three separate
questions anytime we
start one of these
kinematics problems
and this will help
us really figure out
what's happening in the motion.
So the first question
that we want to ask
is, how many objects are moving?
So do we care about more than
one object, and if we do,
we need to make sure to
label each one distinctively.
We also want to know how
many dimensions we need
to care about for each object.
The second question that
we want to ask ourselves
is, how many stages of
motion does each object have?
So for an example,
if you're told
that a bicycle is
initially accelerating
and then, at a certain
time, it stops accelerating,
then you know that that
initial acceleration
is going to have different
equations of motion
than the point in
time where it now has
an acceleration equal to zero.
The final thing that
we want to think about,
we want to figure out what
special conditions there are.
So for example, you might be
told that the cart is initially
at rest.
So what does that
mean in reality?
It means that you can write
down something like, v of 0
is equal to 0, that's
what it means for the cart
to initially be at rest.
v cart is-- v at
time 0 is equal to 0.
So those are the kinds
of special conditions
that you need to pay
attention for in the problem
and that will help
you figure out--
get all of the numbers
or the variables
that you need to
solve your equation.
Once you're done thinking
through these different steps,
the final thing
you should always
do before starting a problem
is draw out your problem,
properly label your
system, and then of course
draw your origin, your
axes, and your unit vectors.
And this way, it
will be easy for you
to organize all of the different
information that you have.